primera gran detención por el caso
ayotzinapa tras conocerse el informe de
la comisión de la verdad que concluyó
que fue un crimen de estado que incluía
agentes de varias instituciones
este día personal policiaco de la
fiscalía general de la república cumplió
la orden de aprehensión solicitada en
contra de jesús m por los delitos de
desaparición forzada tortura y contra la
administración de justicia en el caso
yocsina para jesús murillo fue
procurador bajo la presidencia de peña
nieto- entre los años 2012 a 2015
en esa época supervisó la muy criticada
investigación sobre la desaparición en
2014 de 43 estudiantes de la escuela
normal rural de ayotzinapa en el estado
suroccidental de guerrero sólo los
restos de tres de ellos han sido
encontrados e identificados
en enero de 2015 el procurador prometía
que daría con los culpables nosotros
vamos a hacer todo lo posible por sean
consignados y gestionados y castigados
con toda la fuerza del estado repito
para su ejemplar pero estas palabras se
quedaron en el aire
murillo fue considerado el artífice de
la llamada verdad histórica presentada
en 2015 que afirmaba que los cárteles de
la droga habían matado e incinerados los
restos de los estudiantes investigación
rechazada por la onu familiares y
expertos independientes que sostienen
que esta versión está plagada de errores
y abusos cuando el actual presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador asume el
cargo en 2018 prometió aclarar lo
ocurrido en este caso que enluta a
mexico